the U.S president says there'll be
consequences for Riyadh after the OPEC
plus group led by Saudi Arabia decided
to steeply cut oil production the
organization of petrol exporting
countries announced its decision last
week despite U.S opposition the White
House says President Joe Biden is
willing to work with Congress that's
after a senior senator called for a
freeze on cooperation with Saudi Arabia
from the beginning of the administration
since taking office the president has
been very clear that United States needs
to need a different sort of relationship
with Saudi Arabia he has said that from
very early on and I have said this last
week when OPEC made the decision to
align their energy policy with Russia's
war and War aims and against the
American people further underscores that
reasoning to realign that relationship
to reevaluate that relationship with
Saudi Arabia we are reviewing where we
are currently right now and we'll be
watching closely over the coming weeks
and months as well
well Kimberly halket has more from the
White House
well this is something that has really
been uh concern for many on Capitol Hill
for some time this U.S Saudi
relationship and there has been a
concern about particularly the issue of
Human Rights and so this is something
that many members of Congress not just
from the opposition Republican party but
also from the president's own Democratic
party have been urging the White House
to do not just the Biden Administration
but also the Trump Administration for
many years to reevaluate this
relationship and so this is something
that as we've been reporting the
National Security spokesperson John
Kirby says is now something that the
White House is willing to look at given
the fact that the president did travel
to Saudi Arabia in recent months did
feel that he had a good conversation
with the Saudi Korean Prince Mohammed
bin Salman but they are not happy with
the fact that now there has this been
decision this decision by OPEC to in
fact cut production and so there's a
number of reasons why the White House is
not happy about this decision and one of
the big reasons is that there is a
congressional election that is coming up
in just a matter of weeks in fact in
November and this has really seen to
benefit the president's political
adversaries here in the United States
High Energy prices really are not good
for the president politically and so
that's one reason that this white house
is not happy about this but the other
reason that the White House is not happy
about this is that the fact that this is
really seen as aligning with Russia
let's bring in now mod 1 kabbalan he's
the head of political studies at the
Arab Center for research and policy
studies joins us now from Doha good to
have you with us so first of all
is the Biden Administration do you think
really angry with the Saudis or is this
talk of reevaluating the relationship
the talk of consequences is it really
just about domestic consumption so Biden
looks tough ahead of Elections
well I think they might be angry
because I mean divided message and tries
to interpret the Saudi decision uh as on
the one hand sort of uh uh realignment
by the Saudis or an alignment is with
the Russians on the Ukrainian War
because the Saudis have not been willing
over the bus few months actually to
denounce the Russian the Russian
invasion of Ukraine or to give a clear
stand on the uh on the wall on Ukraine
rather they have taken a neutral
position on on that and they have
actually uh stood by their alliance with
the Russians in Obed because you know I
mean there has been an agreement between
obec and the Russians in 2020 to uh to
cut down oil Productions because the
crisis because of covid-19 have have
planted in in 2020 and they remain
actually very much faithful to that to
that agreement on the other hand also
the abiding Administration and tablet
has already seen as as an attempt maybe
to influence the midterm elections Saudi
U.S relations have not been really warm
over the past two years since the Biden
Administration came to power in early
2021
um you know the President Biden has made
many comments actually that angered the
Saudis of course I mean the Saudis are
saying that decision has been actually
based mainly on economic grounds
this question what options does the
White House have then if it wants to hit
back at Saudi Arabia without undermining
its own interests in the region
yeah I mean this is a very good question
Sammy because one reason for providen
visit to Saudi Arabia last summer
actually was to prevent the Saudis from
drifting towards China and Russia this
is something that is uh worrying the
United States a lot in these these days
so they might be using Force I mean the
Americans they have they have leverage
over this hour can use many tools
actually to put pressure on the Saudis
like for example
stop their arms these for the Saudis
whom they need these arms very much
because of the war in Yemen and because
they are they are facing also
threats from from different places by
Iran and by spice proxies right well on
the other hand as you said I mean the by
the administration might must strike a
balance between the domestic needs on
one hand the pressure by the Congress in
order to do something against the Saudis
but on the other hand they don't want to
go very far in that so that they they
push the Saudis to the lab of the
Chinese and Russians that would
undermine their interests obviously
right let me ask you this question
though is Saudi Arabia really siding
with Russia or is it siding with its own
interests in in supporting OPEC oil Cuts
because when you look at the data oil
prices at least the Brent blend they
were actually dropping since mid-july
about mid-july there were around 110 a
barrel to 84 that was going down 84
about before OPEC cut the prices so was
this really sadly over siding with
Russia or just wanted to keep the oil
prices high it was a pragmatic move
it's as you said Sammy I mean I don't
believe that the Saudis they want
actually to align themselves with Russia
especially now Russia in a pretty weak
position right now and Russia cannot
actually convince it for the U.S
alliance with Saudi Arabia the Saudis
they still need Americans very much as a
as a strong security Ally uh in the mid
of so many challenges I think the
decision by the Saudis have taken
completely based on economic grounds as
you said I mean the dollar prices have
been uh Plumping over the past few
months and the South they need the money
actually they need to keep the price as
high as as possible because they need
that money they have so many schemes and
projects and uh in the in the Kingdom so
so they need all sorts of cash in order
to to keep that going so I don't believe
that the interpretation by the binary
institution that the Saudis are aligning
themselves with Russians to be the
accurate description of the of the
latest out a decision plus this is not
the Saudi decision only this is a
decision by odik and by other by other
oil producing countries all they need
higher prices for oil especially at this
particular time
all right marijuana always good to talk
to you thanks for your analysis on that